in people's arms and
their case numbers have remained
relatively high when we're seeing
falling hospitalizations and falling
numbers of deaths but on wednesday
we receive news of a new variant the
so-called omicron variant and i want to
express my deep gratitude to scientists
in south africa who identified this new
variant and shared the information
widely and immediately
this variant is spreading around the
world with two cases so far identified
here in the uk
as always i must stress this with as
always with a new variant there are many
things that we just cannot know at this
early stage but our scientists are
learning more hour by hour and it does
appear that omicron spreads very rapidly
and can be spread between people who are
double vaccinated
there is also a very extensive mutation
which means it diverges quite
significantly from previous
configurations of the virus
and as a result it might at least in
part
reduce the protection of our vaccines
over time
so we need to take targeted and
proportionate measures now as a
precaution while we find out more and
first
we need to slow down the seeding of this
variant in our country
we need to buy time for our scientists
to understand exactly what we're dealing
with
and for us to get
more people vaccinated and above all to
get more people boosted
as well as to help our nhs prepare in
what is already a challenging winter
so yesterday we took steps to protect
the uk against the variant coming here
from southern african countries and
earlier today added four more countries
to the red list
but we now need to go further and
implement a proportionate testing regime
for arrivals from across the whole world
so
we're not going to stop people traveling
i want to stress that we're not going to
stop people traveling but we will
require anyone who enters the uk to take
a pcr test
by the end of the second day after their
arrival
and
to self-isolate until they have a
negative result
second
we need to slow down the spread of this
variant here in the uk because
measures at the border can only ever
minimize and delay the arrival of a new
variant rather than stop it altogether
so in addition to the measures we're
already taking to locate those who have
been in countries of concern over the
last
10 days
we will require all contacts of those
who test positive with us a suspected
case of omicron to self-isolate for 10
days
regardless of your vaccination status
we will also go further in asking all of
you to help contain the spread of this
variant by tightening up the rules on
face coverings in shops and on public
transport
and third and most importantly we need
to bolster our protections against this
new variant
we don't
yet exactly know how effective our
vaccines will be
against omicron
but we have good reasons for believing
they will provide at least some
measure
of protection
and if you're boosted your response is
likely to be stronger
so it's more vital than ever that people
get their jabs and we get those boosters
into arms as fast as possible
so from today we're going to boost the
booster campaign
we're already planning to do six million
jabs in england alone over the next
three weeks and
now we're looking to go further
so the health secretary has asked the
jcvi the joint committee on vaccination
immunization to consider giving boosters
to as wide a group as possible as well
as reducing the gap between your second
dose and your booster and of course
we're speaking to our counterparts in
the devolved administrations and we'll
continue to coordinate with them
the measures that we're taking today
including on our borders and on face
masks are temporary and precautionary
and we will review them in three weeks
at that point we should have much
greater information about the
continuing effectiveness of our vaccines
i very much hope that we will find that
we continue to be in a strong position
and we can lift these measures again
but right now this is the responsible
course of action to slow down the
seeding in the spread of this new
variant and to maximize our defenses
so that we protect the gains we've
worked for so hard and so that we can
continue to save lives thank you i'm
going to ask chris to do the slides
thank you much prime minister uh first
slide please
um we thought it was sensible to start
off uh with the existing situation which
is almost entirely delta uh because that
is the problem for uh people who are
currently being infected currently in
hospital and currently dying it isn't to
say that delta is worse than on the
chronic is simply to say this is what
the majority by far the majority of
cases at the moment are
so if we look at the current situation
the situation remains that in terms of
numbers of cases uh overall it is in our
view broadly flat sometimes it is going
up and sometimes it is going down it
went up for example yesterday in terms
of numbers of cases but that hides the
fact that in fact there essentially
there are three different patterns
in uh young younger children uh there is
quite significant transmission at this
point in time
and rates are increasing in many parts
of the country at the other end of the
age spectrum as a result of the booster
program almost certainly rates are
beginning to drift downwards in people
over 16 and particularly people above
70.
and the result of that
is that we're seeing an improvement in
the group who are most vulnerable and
then between those ages i would say
broadly uh the rates are flat they're
slightly higher in certain ages and
slightly lower than others but those are
really broadly the three patterns next
slide please
uh as a result of the fact that the
numbers uh in uh the older age groups
and vulnerable people are getting their
booster vaccination
the numbers going into hospital despite
the high and in some areas rising
overall numbers the numbers going to
hospital are gradually decreasing this
is not a sudden drop this is a gradual
drifting down
but
if the numbers overall remain roughly as
they are
we should hope that this should continue
to be the case as the booster campaign
which is very successful very large
numbers of people coming forward
continues to provide significant
additional protection to people over the
next weeks
next slide please
and this is fortunately translating
again into a gradual reduction
in the number of people who are dying of
covid
next slide please
looking at the vaccination program that
the prime minister talked about we're
continuing to see increases in the
number of people coming forward for
their first vaccine
and also
people coming forward for their second
vaccine as part of their primary cause
and that is absolutely essential anybody
who is not vaccinated can uh i please
strongly encourage you to do so
the rates are already very high with
delta and we now we now have this new
risk uh coming through
next slide please
and when we look at the booster program
uh the rates of this are going uh very
well at the moment as you can see day by
day uh the number of people who are
getting this significant additional
protection from the booster are
increasing so that's the summary in
terms of the overall epidemic now just
moving on to a few additional facts on
the omicron
variant
just to add to what the prime minister
has said
we we know that has their cases have uh
been uh seen out of uh four countries in
southern africa not just
south africa and we know that they've
been imported into several countries
around the world including hong kong
which uh reported one of the first uh
cases uh belgium uh and uh
most recent reports suggesting germany
and now in the uk
we expect the numbers to continue to
rise around the world over the next few
days that is that is our very strong
expectation and the numbers of countries
that will be reporting this will
continue to rise that is i think uh
virtually inevitable
here in the uk as the prime minister
says there are two uh cases that have uh
been formally reported uh the first in
essex and the second in nottingham both
of those are linked together so they're
part of the same cluster these are not
independent cases they're part of
the same cluster and they have they are
helping all the public health
authorities uh they are self-isolating
and there is contact tracing going on by
the uk health security agency
around all of these
i just wanted to say a little bit about
how the virus with the reason that we
are concerned about this virus and
essentially it is the prime minister
said two different uh things the first
question is uh
is a virus capable of spreading and this
one is spreading rapidly in many areas
so for example in in the gauteng
area of south africa uh up to 90 percent
of the cases that have been reported and
genotyped uh are we are told
are of this new variant so spread is
clear and it's spreading around the
world so to achieve the first thing it
definitely can spread
second question is uh to what extent is
that because it is able to escape
immunity from prior infection or from
vaccination we do not at this stage know
and uh but what we do know is that there
are quite extensive mutations on the
spike protein which is an important part
of the
virus and the reason that is important
is that is the bit which all the
vaccines are against and indeed which
most natural immunity is against so
there is a reasonable chance that at
least there will be some degree of
vaccine escape with this variant
now an important thing which we've said
previously with other uh
bits of immunity with viruses is that uh
the it is easier for the virus to
achieve
ability to escape for infection
than it is to achieve escape for severe
disease
and then on to mortality so there is a
reasonable chance but i want to be clear
we need to wait until we have data
before we can say this with any
certainty
that even if there is some or
significant escape from the ability to
infect someone and therefore for them to
be infectious it may be that the still
vaccines
in particular when they've had boosters
and natural infection boosted by
vaccination may be sufficient to go on
prevent people from going on to having
severe disease and in some cases
dying so that is the reason that the
prime minister has emphasized so
strongly the need to
boost on top of a primary course because
the stronger the immune system responds
the more it is able to deal with a
relative disadvantage due to the genetic
makeup of this virus i'm now going to
pass over to sir patrick who's going to
add to those points so viruses will
continue to change and they change all
the time there have been many variants
the reason this one is worrying as chris
has said is the combination of
transmissibility
and the potential for some degree of
escape from vaccines because of the
number of changes
that means therefore there are three
things that need to be done as the prime
minister said the first is to try to
limit the number of cases that enter the
country from places that have got lots
of cases
and that means check trying to detect
people
and prevent them from spreading in the
country the second is to make sure that
when we do have cases in the country and
we will have cases just as other
countries will have
that we try and limit spread in the
country
and that means detecting those cases
making sure the contacts are identified
and that clusters are identified and
contained
and the third is to bolster
and the defenses are first and foremost
to make sure that the vaccines
are boosted because very high levels of
antibody coverage
will create a higher proportion of
people protected even against a variant
and secondly to make sure also that
we've got the antivirals that are coming
along which won't be susceptible to the
same degree of resistance uh to this
particular set of changes so defenses
are the third important part of this as
we uh go into this next phase but at the
moment there are a few cases that need
to be identified they need to be
properly looked after in terms of
contact tracing and we need to make sure
that we reduce spread
thank you very much uh chris and patrick
let's go to the to the media ian watson
bbc
thank you very much
um i think we're all hoping that we were
seeing the beginning of the end of the
pandemic but i think people will be
concerned listening to you today they're
actually seeing the beginning of new
restrictions you've said they'll be
reviewed in three weeks time how likely
is it that those restrictions could be
ratcheted up in three weeks time rather
than wound down and can you say with any
confidence at the moment
that people can keep their christmas
plans and if i may ask sir patrick you
said a previous press conference that
you have to go hard and you have to go
early arguably you're going early but
not hard this is falling short of full
plan b with advice to work from home
vaccine passports and so on um
have people amongst your sage advisors
been pushing for full plan b now and if
not why not and finally uh professor
britta if you could answer this
the government is going much quicker
this time than it did over delta um is
that because you're learning lessons
from the pandemic or is it because you
really are far more scared about this
variant than the one that's currently
prevalent thank you uh thanks very much
ian that just just on your your very
good point about uh is this you know are
we going hard enough why aren't we doing
uh plan b i think the key thing to
understand is that you've got two
variants in play here and they require
they required a different approach so
what we're doing with we think that the
measures we have uh are right for
dealing with uh with delta and and their
proportionate and uh and right you
you've heard from chris about the uh
what's happening with case numbers and
also with hospitalizations with with the
measures we have in place and uh we
think that this is the right approach to
omicron uh given the uncertainties that
we have and uh the need to take a
precautionary approach with a with a
with an incoming uh variant from
elsewhere about which we simply don't
yet know enough so it's two different
variants that
require uh two uh simultaneous
strategies if you like and on your your
point about uh
where we are overall in the in the
pandemic i think i would just repeat
what i said at the beginning that i
think the uk continues to be in a in a a
much much stronger uh position we
continue to be in a in a strong position
largely thanks to the the speed of the
vaccine rollout and neither the booster
rollout and as for your your question
about uh about christmas i think i'm
going to stick with the formula i've
used before which is that i'm i'm pretty
confident or absolutely confident this
uh christmas will be considerably better
uh than last christmas if if
if you if that will do for the time
being on on that one um
i mean you're quite right
the the thing that we need to do is
always think in the face of this virus
go earlier than you think you want to
harder than you think you want to and
more geographically broad than you think
you want to those are the principles and
that remains true here but of course the
specifics of this are different because
this isn't now widespread variant in the
uk it's one that's coming in therefore
we need to make sure we've got the right
measures in place to detect it
we need to make sure we can pick up the
clusters in the country as quickly as
possible contain those and to make sure
that we've got contact tracing and
isolation of contacts
and importantly we must boost the
defenses that we have which is why
booster vaccines are so important and go
really
hard and quick to get those booster
vaccines across as many people as
possible reinforce the need that anyone
who hasn't had a vaccine should get it
anyone who's eligible for a booster now
and hasn't had it you get it because
that's going to give
them the high antibody levels and the
high response which stands the best
chance of actually stopping this from
causing problems in terms of severe
disease and deaths
you asked me i mean i think we're
learning lessons the whole time uh i
think it is important to stress that the
the risk here is different to delta
delta it was primarily driven by the
ability to spread really rapidly but
less concern about the vaccination
escape this one here really the biggest
thing that is leading us to which to
move rapidly is to do with the uh at
least strong theoretical reasons for
thinking that some degree of vaccine
escape is likely given the number of
mutations but there's obviously much
longer answer than that thank you uh
nick martin sky
good evening everyone um just firstly to
you prime minister can you just be a bit
clearer about what you said about face
coverings
you said it would be necessary to
tighten up on them are you tonight
saying that you are going to make face
coverings mandatory in whatever indoor
spaces and just to professor valance sir
patrick and professor witte
have you
looked at
have you muddled the potential spread of
this new variant over the next few weeks
and months
what picture does that show
and can we really rule out
lockdowns as a result of what you know
about this
variant
uh nick thank you very much on on face
coverings that what we're looking at is
uh retail and and transport to just just
going back to a position where you have
to wear them in in retail settings or on
uh or on public transport but the health
secretary saj will be sending out more
uh in in the course the next day or so
in terms of uh the modeling of this you
know as a model you need some
information around the
increased degree of transmissibility or
otherwise and that's still being
collected so we don't yet have enough
information to know exactly
whether this is more transmissible if so
by how much what we do know from south
africa and chris has alluded to this is
there are pockets of rapidly growing
outbreaks but that's a rather different
situation so we're trying to get that
information i have to say the south
african scientists have been absolutely
brilliant they've been brilliant at
detecting it they've been brilliant at
sharing that information and that's been
very helpful to the whole world actually
um so i think we'll get more information
on transmissibility we'll get more
information on the
um ability of this facts of the vaccines
to
protect against the virus but that's
going to take a little bit of time and
so at the moment i'm afraid the models
are more sort of if it spreads very fast
of course it's going to spread very fast
and go into a lot of places and if it
spreads less fast it's going to do so
less we can't really get much further
than that but if it's very transmissible
and obviously does cause big escape then
clearly that's that's that's a major
issue to face up to but that isn't what
we know at the moment we need to get
that information
great thanks sir vincent mcaveny itv
news
thank you prime minister probably so
there'll be people watching this
wondering why you're not going further
into plan b and ordering people to work
from home if that might help us actually
have something towards a normal
christmas and reduce the spread also
things like having vaccine passports and
using the check-in apps once again so
why aren't you doing that at this point
also for you there have been calls over
the last year for developing developed
nations to help more developing nations
roll out the vaccine is this now
evidence that we should have done more
in the past year to do that with
international partners
and for uh sir patrick and professor
witte on the
vaccination scheme you said you're going
to boost the booster rollout what does
that mean is the age going to come down
and for vaccinations for those under 12
and second vaccinations for those age 12
to 15 are we going to see that coming
shortly as well thank you
thanks
a very very important point uh uh
vincent but i want to go back to what i
was saying about the the difference
between uh
delta and an omicron and the need to uh
to have slightly different tactics to to
cope with them when you when you look at
uh at a delta uh the measures that we
have in in place uh are
are
effective in the sense that you're
seeing this downwards tracking of of
hospitalizations and and deaths as
assisted by uh the booster program and
and by the massive take-up of vaccines
and that's the the key take-out i hope
from uh this briefing today is that the
best way to beat the this piece of news
is for everybody to get their uh their
booster but for omicron what you what
you need to do is is to try to slow the
the seeding uh with the the border
measures that we're taking the the tough
measures that we're taking at the uh at
the border uh in order to to
give us time to find out exactly what
the risk is but more importantly uh to
uh allow that boost to pro could give
give us time to have uh another you know
six million uh boosters in in people's
arms we think that would be uh that will
be uh very valuable and
um so you had a second question forgive
me yeah there'd be many calls to help
developing nations yes i'm sorry on on
vaccines around the world uh
that is something that um i think the uk
can be incredibly proud of and we've
we've done a huge amount to vaccinate
the world
don't forget that uh one and a half
billion uh doses have been delivered at
cost thanks to the deal the uk
government did uh with astrazeneca and i
think when you when you look at the
arrival of this and the the spread of
omicron sadly it's been it's been inc in
countries where the problem has not been
to supply
a vaccine it's been it's been ready to
do with with with hesitancy and a lack
of take-up so uh i think that you know
there might be many uh
we do need to do more to vaccinate the
world uh the uk has been has been
leading in that but i i don't think i
mean i'd defer to to
to
chris and chris and patrick i don't
think that that is the uh
the issue here
on the question you asked about um
extending the numbers so uh the joint
committee on vaccination immunization
jcvi uh which gives the advice to the
government
is taking into account the fact this
really changes the risks benefit
calculations for several of the
decisions which they still have to take
which includes extending down
in the age range
into younger adults for example for
boosters so they will reassess
decisions they've taken and decide
whether in the light of this new
information and they'll do this rapidly
in the light of this new information
they wish to advise an extension beyond
the groups that are there already
i've got nothing great thanks david
maddox sunday express
thank you prime minister
um
can you uh or a question for all three
of you really can you be
clear to people about your level of
concern compared to big delta viral
variant
last year
and is it that the circumstances have
changed so much that we
can be less concerned
than this time last year can you
appreciate that given how rapidly things
developed last year but people will be
worried especially the hospitality
industry about christmas
should people in that industry should
others be taking precautionary measures
at this point
on that basis
regarding the jcbi
review of vaccines can you give some
more of a rationale
to extending it downwards given that
there is a significant group of parents
who are worried
about the effect of vaccines on children
and the
evidence so far that suggests that
children aren't as badly affected by the
virus as other age groups and finally
on vaccine passports what is the
likelihood of those being introduced and
are you looking at the
outcomes in scotland which suggests that
it hasn't had an impact so far on the
spread of violence
thank you very much david i think i'm
going to ask chris and patrick to
comment on vaccination of younger people
and and
vaccination children in in particular
but just on your point about hospitality
there's as you'll have seen there's
nothing uh that we've announced uh
tonight uh that changes the position for
false brutality and i'm just gonna
repeat uh what i've said i believe that
as a result of the vaccination program
and of the the booster program uh that
is going very very fast now that the uk
is in a much much stronger position and
it's in order to retain that strong
position that we're taking the sensible
precautionary steps uh that we're taking
today and i continue to uh you know i
repeat what i said about uh
my formula about christmas uh that i'm
you i i've every reason to think that it
will be considerably better uh david
than last year
on the jcbi um question uh so there are
broadly three
sets of questions they're going to look
at the first one is actually extending
down in adults down to people 18 for a
booster vaccination and i do think
that's probably the most urgent of the
decisions they will have to take
there's then a question about a second
dose for
children who've chosen to take the
children's families have chosen to take
the first dose
and those
aged 12 to 15 they've already decided
that this should be extended to
young people
16 and 17
and
the evidence on that i think uh is
broadly been as evidence has come in it
has made us more reassured about safety
rather than less reassured by its safety
so and we are you know i think most
parents would agree
that there are now significant outbreaks
amongst those who are not vaccinated in
schools indeed some among some who are
vaccinated there is there is a
significant issue in children of that
age
and that therefore clearly should be
looked at by jcvi and then they will
look additionally at the younger age
groups and they will take a view as to
whether they think the evidence is clear
enough obviously some uh countries like
the usa have already decided to go in
that direction that jcvi are an
independent committee they will take the
decision based on the sciences in front
of them but to be you know to go back to
this point about uh you know
were we more concerned or less concerned
the point we have at the moment is
there's a lot of uncertainty
about the new omicron
variant and because of that uncertainty
it is sensible to take a precautionary
approach until we know uh which way
things are going and do that rather than
look back and which we've done so before
yeah i mean just just to add to that i
mean i think the one thing that i think
makes people concerned and that's why
there's so much interest in this is the
number of mutations and the way in which
that might
change
uh the immune system's recognition of
the virus which is how you get um
vaccine escape so that's that's why
people are concerned about this but as
chris said this huge uncertainty about
exactly how that translates into
protection and that's what needs to be
looked at
reasons to be
overall
much less concerned in the long run is
because
we've got vaccines that are effective
the vaccine manufacturers actually can
change them quite easily so we've got a
very changeable platform of vaccines now
and we've got drugs coming along
anti-viral drugs which work so we've got
a far greater armamentarium than we had
months ago and certainly in a totally
transformed picture compared to a year
ago
i
certainly agree with that uh david
williams son
uh prime minister um i want to push you
a little bit more on christmas please
because the thing which is at the
forefront of our minds i take your view
that uh you will have a better christmas
and i'm glad to hear that but can you
for the sake of you people watching and
for our readers uh say how important it
is to use these mitigations wearing your
mask and all the other things in order
to have a good christmas this year um
could i also ask a couple of you your
two experts um uh uh professor whitley
you mentioned that some people might
have a bit of
fatigue about
abiding by uh the restrictions after two
years of this do you think that there'll
be any problems in that area with this
new variant as we try to get people back
into some more restricted lifestyle and
sir patrick um
how long do you think it would take to
get a vaccine tweaked that might be able
to deal with this once we take into
account we need to have the fact before
we do that and secondly the amateur
scientists among us uh were saying a
couple of days ago when we first heard
about this variant uh that uh
if it's there it's already in britain
and so it came to pass that it is so
with the amateur scientists now thinking
oh gosh it's going to be spreading
through britain rapidly it'll let red
before long is that something we need to
fear about or how can you calm us down
on that one thank you
so so david i just really to repeat what
i've uh said before uh the the thing
about as chris and patrick have said uh
it is it is pretty clear uh that uh if
you
no matter what the effects of this uh
new variant if you're uh vaccinated in
it in particular if you have a booster
your immune response is likely uh to be
to be stronger so the best thing you can
do the best thing everybody can do is
get your get your booster and the
stronger the overall uh position will be
we'll all be in as i say as we go
forward to christmas we are in a strong
position but uh the objective of what
we're doing uh tonight is to is to keep
that position strong
in the question you asked me i mean i
i i was uh puzzled by some of the
headlines i read uh of what i said uh
this morning because they brought no
relationship in my view to what i
actually said but that sometimes happens
i'm sure it doesn't happen under any of
your watches
and uh what i said was asking a
rhetorical question
the uk public have been absolutely
extraordinary
at responding when they have it
explained to them why to do it and my
point and my central point was only if
you're going to ask people to do
something lay out all the data very
clearly explain it very honestly and so
that people understand why it is that
you're asking something to do something
that was the point i was making quite
how it turned into uh what it was
reported as i don't fully understand but
i mean that was the point and if i can
make one christmas plea
it would be that when people raise their
glasses at christmas they do so to the
extraordinary scientists who produce the
vaccines the diagnostics the drugs which
will allow this christmas as the prime
minister said to be in a very different
place to what it would have been without
them yeah yeah thank you very much on
the
on the question about um vaccines and
and how long it takes i think i think
it's important to recognize there are
three ways in which this can be done and
the companies are all thinking about
this the first is that boosters will
give high enough antibody coverage that
actually that's going to
be enough to cover this that's the first
and and needs to be tested but that that
looks like something that anyway is
going to
give protection whether there's more
needed on top of that we'll have to see
the second is that vaccine manufacturers
have been producing broader vaccines
anyway to get broader coverage across
potential new variants so those are in
the pipeline
and then a couple of companies have
already said they could tweak their
existing vaccines and get a new vaccine
out specifically against this in about
100 days
and so those are the sort of three
scenarios clearly the one which is the
one to really go for now is boost
because
it is the case that as you keep boosting
with the vaccine
you get slightly broader coverage
because the immune system knows it needs
to get broader and because the antibody
levels are so high it actually causes
enough coverage of other variants to be
effective so i think that's really why
the boosting is so important
um
the spread of the variant i mean the
amateur um scientists were in line with
the professional scientists which is
you're not going to stop these things
from going around the world we've seen
that time and time again new variants
that have significant transmissibility
advantage will spread so the question on
this one is does it have significant
transmissibility advantage those data
are being looked at and collected
so we do expect it to spread you can
delay the spread by actions
you won't stop it and you can see that
now delta is pretty much everywhere and
depending on what omicron does in terms
of its transmissibility it might either
spread or it gets halted because delta
out-competes it and we just don't know
yet
thanks so hugo guy the eye
thank you um can i can i press you prime
minister on on the question of the jcvi
are you hoping that they will report
back on uh whether or not to broaden
boosters by the end of this coming week
or
is it going to take a bit longer than
that uh and can i ask professor witty uh
when do you expect antiviral treatments
such as malnour piravir and paxlavid
which the uk already has on order to be
deployed in the nhs for the first time
uh hugo thanks very much a good good
question about the jcvi but they are
they are an independent uh body and uh
uh but clearly uh that we hope that
we'll we'll get some answers for
everybody as as soon as possible but um
on the antivirals uh i mean and patrick
may want to add to this because uh but
on the antenna virals we are going to
have to do a bit of a rethink in the
basis of this new variant just to be
confident we got the right indications
for it because there are a variety of
ways you could use it in different ways
and what we need to make sure is
whatever stock we've got of these
what appear to be highly effective drugs
that we use uh in the most effective way
and for the right people because where
you are in the pathway right from the
very beginning when people as
prophylaxis all the way through to
treating people in intensive care
putting working out their place
we do need to think through and i think
we probably need to do a rethink of it
just to make sure that with the new
variant we're actually targeting in the
right direction good thanks we got will
james from be it will yes that's me yes
uh was it a mistake not to close the
border sooner or rather
tighten the travel restrictions and uh
will you be considering
uh
sorry adding countries like belgium and
others where the omicron variants being
reported to the red list thanks will
well i thank you very much i i i would i
really don't know how we could have
acted uh faster we got we got the news
on i was told about it on i think
thursday and we and we we closed the the
uh we put uh quite a lot of southern
african countries on the red list uh
yesterday uh uh some more today and what
we're announcing uh is some tough
measures for i'm afraid for everybody uh
traveling so that you you you know you
have to do a pcr test as soon as you get
back here and you've got to isolate for
48 hours until you get a negative result
and i'm afraid uh that that may sound
tough but that is just the way it's got
to be
okay thank you everybody thank you thank
you
okay that was the prime minister boris
johnson
alongside professor chris whittie and
sir patrick valance
the
top um points from that press conference
for you then are that uh masks are now
back we have to wear them in shops and
public transport the prime minister
originally said we are to tighten the
rules and that the health secretary
sergeant jarvid would
uh be giving us more details on that
pushed by our correspondent nick martin
he said that masks are mandatory we will
have to wear them in
shops and public transport from now on
uh the other points were that we will
now have to have a pcr test anyone
traveling into the united kingdom has to
have a pcr test remember that was
changed to a lateral flow on arrival and
to self-isolate until they get a
negative result
to that end anyone who is a contact of
someone testing positive or with links
to the current variant the omnichrome
variant will have to self-isolate
regardless of vaccination for 10 days
and
the other point the prime minister made
was encouraging everyone to get that
all-important vaccination and the
booster jab they're saying they're
looking at whether they will widen the
group that can receive that booster jab
and in fact reduce the time and gap
between the second dose and the booster
jab they are going to ask the jcvi uh
about that to get their input this
review
this will be reviewed in three weeks
time the prime minister saying that this
is temporary and precautionary as far as
these measures are concerned let's bring
in uh health correspondent ashish joshi
uh ashish clearly the uh restrictions on
flights were for
the uh uk to buy some time to assess
this variant further but now of course
the prime minister going further
yeah it was to slow the spread and make
sure that there are no uh fast spreading
clusters of omicron all the points that
you've highlighted simon uh absolutely
yeah
there will not be a
a ban on travel travel continues but
with more restrictions and that is to
try and identify anyone coming into the
country with this new strain of virus so
we have the pcr and the isolation the
contacts of omicrons being told to
self-isolate omicron cases to
self-isolate for 10 days and
interestingly the
the nod to the jcvi the thing about the
booster jabs uh being rolled out to
younger cohorts younger age groups and
also the reduction in the gap between
jabs now these are all
interventions that the prime minister
can make right now to try and stop
this omicron variant from spreading as
quickly as delta did he said it was to
stop it seeding and spreading so that's
what they're doing surveillance local
surveillance will be boosted wherever
there's an identification of a case and
there'll be surge testing in those areas
but essentially we heard from the two
scientists who who told us why they were
so worried in particular about this
variant they said it wasn't the spread
of omicron that worried them they said
delta was much faster at spreading so
that wasn't the issue here it's the way
this vaccine has mutated and it spiked
protein making it um
more likely to evade the vaccine and
that's a real concern so there was a
little bit of a warning there from the
scientists about how potentially
dangerous this new variant could be with
the vaccines in deployment at the moment
but also
some hope that
speaking to the vaccine manufacturers
the people who produce these vaccines
some um reassurance that the vaccines we
have at the moment will offer a degree
of protection even from this new variant
so get vaccinated get boosted make sure
you have a high level of protection that
will stop you becoming very sick even
with this new vaccine but again and
again and again we were told we still
don't have the data we don't know enough
about omicron even though the south
african scientists have been excellent
in in trying to gather as much data as
they can it's simply too soon to know
what sort of impact omicron will have
with the current vaccines but again the
vaccine
developers are confident that they can
make tweaks to their vaccines in up to a
hundred days to have a omicron res
omicron ready vaccine so that's three
months down the line but christmas is a
month away what do we do
between now and christmas is to
interview to to make these interventions
without going fully to plan b so yes you
have the mandatory face masks on public
transport and in shops and
you will have more people now being
encouraged to take this boost especially
if it's spread out to the younger cohort
so the government acting quite quickly
quite decisively making sure that it can
make the interventions it has to right
now to try and stop the spread of
omicron in this country
and ashes the fact that they're all set